nouveau numéro de reporter le dock le
magazine de reportage long format de
France 24 la Coupe du monde de football
se tient au Qatar à partir du 20
novembre mais à mesure qu'approche la
date de la cérémonie d'ouverture le pays
haute voix grandir contre lui les
critiques contre cette compétition qui
pour beaucoup est une aberration
écologique mais aussi un scandale humain
à cette occasion nos journalistes se
sont intéressés au sort de ces milliers
de travailleurs migrants qui ont bâti
les stades et les infrastructures ça a
l'air impayés passeport confisqué
conditions de travail extrême qui ont
causé la mort de plusieurs milliers
d'entre eux face à la pression
internationale le Qatar a fait évoluer
son droit du travail mais les
répercussions sur le terrain semblent
encore insuffisante selon les ONG le
reportage de Chloé Domart et rame
patareya mettant lumière le quotidien de
celles et ceux pour qui le rêve s'est
transformé en cauchemar mais il montre
aussi ceux qui ont trouvé des
opportunités qui leur étaient interdites
dans leur pays d'origine Catha les
travailleurs de l'ombre c'est un
document France 24
[Musique]
c'est gratte-ciel sont à la hauteur des
ambitions démesurées du Qatar
mais ceux qui ont construit les tours de
Doha n'auront jamais les moyens d'y
habiter
[Musique]
loin du centre-ville au bout de ses
autoroutes
pour nous y rendre un travailleur Kean
nous guide
il accepte de témoigner à condition
d'être anonyme nous l'appelons Ibrahim
il dit avoir payé 1500 euros à une
agence de recrutement kenyan pour son
visa et son billet d'avion
ce n'est qu'une fois sur place en 2020
qu'il découvre l'entreprise catharienne
qu'il a embauché
quand je suis arrivé le jour même j'ai
commencé à travailler
au début on faisait du ciment pour des
immeubles de la construction quoi
ici la température monte parfois au
dessus de 52 degrés c'est pas facile
quand on travaille dehors la chaleur
nous écrase
on a l'impression qu'on va mourir
comme la majorité des travailleurs
étrangers
Ibrahim est logé par son employeur à des
dizaines de kilomètres du centre-ville
dans ces immensités dortoirs isolées de
tout
tous les soirs les ouvriers sont ramenés
des chantiers par les bus de leurs
entreprises
sans autre moyen de transport ces hommes
se retrouvent prisonniers du désert
quand il nous va marcher comme ça la
nuit
la sécurité appelle la police
il pense qu'on veut s'enfuir du camp
à son arrivée
Ibrahim s'était filmé avec ses collègues
ils étaient alors plein d'espoir leur
nouvel employeur promettait un salaire
deux à trois fois plus élevé que dans
leur pays d'origine logement et repas
prise en charge
première désillusion le camp ressemble à
une décharge
voilà comment on vit au Qatar à Doha
ça sent mauvais
ici est un enfer
personne ne doit savoir que je fais ça
au Qatar publié des images négatives du
pays et passibles d'expulsion
c'est quand sont interdits d'accès aux
journalistes mais excédé par leurs
conditions de vie
Ibrahim et ses compagnons de chambrer
prennent le risque de nous faire entrer
avec une caméra
depuis les premiers jours ces ouvriers
ont nettoyé eux-mêmes ce qu'ils
pouvaient mais il manque encore de tout
voilà c'est notre logement
c'est regarder venez à l'intérieur
la nuit il y a des gens qui dorment par
terre on fait comme ça
pourquoi il nous laisse là
l'entreprise avait dit qu'elle nous
donnerait des lits qu'elle nous
donnerait à manger
mais ici pas de cantine ni de frigo ni
même un endroit pour cuisiner
voilà comment on prépare à manger
on essaie juste de survivre
regardez ça c'est ce qu'on achète on ne
nous donne pas de repas c'est ça qu'on
mange
ce qui nous arrive on en peut plus
on est fatigué voilà c'est tout
en plus de ce logement insalubre ces
travailleurs affirment ne pas avoir été
payé depuis des mois
tous les jours ils disent qu'on va
toucher notre salaire mais il ne donne
rien
ça fait presque un an et il n'y a pas
que moi tous mes amis aussi
on a essayé d'en parler à l'employeur
mais il a menacé d'appeler la police
certains veulent rentrer dans leur pays
d'autres voudraient changer d'entreprise
mais l'employeur a confisqué nos
passeports
c'est une violation des droits de
l'homme ce n'est pas juste
ce n'est pas juste de vivre comme ça
allez faut y aller
comme Ibrahim plus de 2,5 millions
d'étrangers vivent et travaillent au
Qatar
le richissime émirats fait venir cette
main d'oeuvre d'Asie et d'Afrique grâce
à l'argent des hydrocarbures
ces immigrés représentent 90% de la
population
ce sont eux qui ont construit toutes les
infrastructures pour la Coupe du Monde
l'aéroport le métro les hôtels de luxe
et bien sûr ces stades flambant neufs
[Musique]
rien que pour celui-ci 8000 ouvriers se
sont relayés jour et nuit pendant 4 ans
à l'extérieur ce mur est censé leur
rendre hommage mais ces photos
d'identité interrogent plutôt sur le
nombre d'ouvriers sacrifiés au nom de la
folie des grandeurs
[Musique]
les cathariens eux voient déjà au-delà
du championnat de football
le pays a postulé aux Jeux olympiques et
rêve de devenir une capitale mondiale
des événements sportifs
je ressens une grande fierté que Dieu
nous ait donné la chance d'organiser la
Coupe du monde le
Qatar est un pays ambitieux les cherche
à accueillir les plus grands tournois
internationaux
nous avons maintenant l'infrastructure
et les stats pour cela je pense que le
Qatar est prêt à recevoir n'importe quel
événement sportif notre ambition ne
s'arrêtera pas à la Coupe du monde
pour cette première Coupe du monde
organisée au Moyen-Orient le Qatar
espère attirer un million et demi de
supporters et fans de football
quatre semaines de divertissement rendu
possible grâce au travail acharné de
centaines de milliers de petites mains
[Musique]
dans un centre commercial de Doha nous
accompagnons ces employés Philippines
nous filmons au téléphone pour ne pas
être arrêté par la sécurité
Rachel en t-shirt noir envoie chaque
mois presque tout son salaire environ
400 euros à ses 5 enfants
c'est important pour votre famille oui
ils attendent mon salaire je leur envoie
[Musique]
dans les allées de marbre deux univers
se croisent
tout en haut de l'échelle sociale les
foyers catariens ont un revenu moyen de
20.000 euros par mois pour eux le centre
commercial est un parc d'attraction ou
rien n'est trop cher
à l'extrême opposé Rachel et ses amis se
contentent de regarder
vous prenez une photo de quoi du décor
je prends ça en photo
vous allez l'envoyer à qui
à mes enfants pour leur montrer
l'intérieur du centre commercial
arrivé au Qatar en 2018 rachel travaille
pour un salon de beauté tenu par une
catharienne
sa patronne l'envoie faire des manucures
pédicures et massages à domicile
c'est moi qui ai fait ces faux ongles
d'habitude on commence vers 9h du matin
et on travaille jusqu'à 20h30 le soir
ces femmes sont logées par leur patronne
et non pas le droit de sortir seul
en trois ans elle disent n'avoir jamais
eu de vacances
même quand son mari est mort l'année
dernière Rachel n'a pas pu prendre une
seule journée de repos
vous avez des jours de congés des congés
non non aujourd'hui c'est la première
fois qu'on a un jour entier de repos
la toute première fois
théoriquement on a le droit à un jour de
pause par mois
mais on donne que quelques heures de 3
heures pas plus
vous saviez ça avant de venir au Qatar
non oui non oui on savait c'est dans le
contrat qu'on a signé
mais souvent au Qatar il ne respecte pas
la loi sur les congés
au
Qatar et puis finalement non
mais aujourd'hui on a de la chance la
patronne nous a libéré
un seul jour de congé en trois ans
s'est-il légal même au Qatar
mais Rachel et ses amis espèrent que
leur sacrifice paieront un jour
souvent pauvre à l'arrivée ces immigrés
venus des quatre coins du monde rêve
d'ascension sociale
leur modèle ceux qui ont réussi à
accéder à la classe moyenne
enseignant infirmiers ou comptable il
travaille dans les hôtels les
restaurants tiennent des commerces et
des petites entreprises
sans eux le pays ne pourrait pas
fonctionner
au premier étage de cette immeuble cette
entreprise de filtre à eau est tenue par
une indienne
par zanacher 47 ans et fier de montrer
sa réussite bonjour bonjour Comment ça
va
nous vendons des fontaines à eau comme
celle-ci ok le filtre élimine le sel et
le chlore de l'eau car ici à Doha
vous pouvez vous servir de l'eau froide
avec ce robinet et pour le thé et le
café vous obtenez de l'eau chaude ici
va bien se passer dans la joie et la
bonne humeur et surtout qu'on fasse des
affaires
le mois dernier vous avez bien travaillé
je suis contente c'est très bien
continuez comme ça
a commencé il y a 22 ans comme simple
vendeuse
aujourd'hui elle dirige 14 personnes
tous viennent du sous continent indien
et touche environ 10 fois plus que dans
leur pays
mais ils ont intérêt à le mériter
alors ragens quel est ton objectif ce
mois-ci laisse-moi 15000 ce n'est pas
assez pour toi non plus 15000 ce n'est
pas assez assez focus tu viens de
rentrer de vacances
faisan et toi
c'est mon Gagnepain c'est tout pour moi
ma maison mon bureau tout est à Doha
c'est pour ça que vous êtes venu au
Qatar bien sûr
et dieu soit loué le Qatar m'a tout
donné
chaque mois farsana reçoit une dizaine
de CV de nouveau candidats à
l'immigration
pour ces Indiens le Qatar représente une
sorte d'eldorado
je suis venu car je pense que le Qatar
est un endroit excitant où il y a
beaucoup d'opportunités
[Musique]
pour gagner de l'argent ou acquérir de
l'expérience c'est pour ça qu'on vient
ici
allez vous pouvez retourner travailler
merci beaucoup
les gens à l'étranger meurent d'envie de
venir ici ils ont l'impression que des
lingots d'or poussent sur les arbres
qu'ils vont venir et que ça sera facile
mais ce n'est pas si simple la réussite
c'est de la sueur et des larmes
réussir à Doha à un prix
la loi oblige par Zana à être parrainé
par un qatarien
ce système qui maintient les étrangers
sous tutelle s'appelle la kafala
et femme si vous n'êtes pas catarin
comme moi qui viens d'Inde et que vous
voulez monter une entreprise il faut
avoir un associé local c'est associé
prend 51% des parts et c'est lui qui
possède la société et il prend 51% du
profit non non
comment ça marche
le sponsor prend quelque chose chaque
mois c'est-à-dire on fixe une somme de
combien il touche chaque mois
on doit accepter ces conditions vous
savez il faut savoir faire des
concessions et se plier en quatre pour
avancer en affaires il faut se montrer
flexible
je ne peux pas être trop exigeante parce
qu'en fin de compte c'est leur pays
[Musique]
dit bien s'entendre avec son associé
une chance pour elle car en cas de
conflit la voix des résidents étrangers
ne pèse pas lourd face à celle des
catariens
[Musique]
dans une galerie marchande nous
retrouvons Ibrahim après presque un
ancien salaire les patrons qui
l'exploitent l'ont transféré ici
on nous a fait venir dans ce centre
commercial pour travailler
jusqu'à 13 heures par jour
sa nouvelle tâche remplir les sacs de
commission et désinfecter les caddie de
ce supermarché une franchise de la
marque française carrefour pour les pays
du Golfe
[Musique]
son entreprise de sous-traitance
qatarienne lui présente ce poste comme
une promotion car elle lui assure qu'il
touchera des pourboires en plus d'un
salaire mensuel de 400 euros
le gérant nous avait dit vous aurez les
pourboires c'est bien pour vous
accumulez les pourboires ça vous fera
entre 15 et 30 euros et avec ça vous
pourrez acheter à manger
moi au début je voulais refuser
je ne voulais pas ce genre de travail
parce que je ne sais pas si les gens
vont donner ou pas de l'argent
les trois premiers mois on n'a pas
touché de salaire au bout de trois mois
on s'est mis en grève
a dit le prochain qui se met en grève
sera expulsé du pays
le chantage fonctionne et les grévistes
reprennent le travail
quatre mois plus tard comme ils ne sont
toujours pas payés
Ibrahim et ses collègues protestent à
nouveau
au Qatar les syndicats sont interdits et
au nom de la sécurité le régime réprime
sévèrement toutes les manifestations
par hasard le ministère du Travail se
trouve juste en face du supermarché
on a décidé d'aller au tribunal du
ministère du Travail quand on est arrivé
on leur a expliqué notre situation et
ils ont dit qu'ils allaient s'occuper de
nous
mais qu'il ne voulait plus nous voir
faire grève
quelques minutes après ça la police est
arrivée on a été arrêté conduit au poste
et puis certains ont été relâchés moi
j'ai été relâché mais mes amis ont été
expulsés
nous avons demandé à visiter ces
tribunaux dont Parly Brahim
le Qatar les a ouvert en 2018 pour
répondre aux critiques internationales
sur le traitement des ouvriers à
l'approche de la Coupe du monde
nous entrons accompagné par des
fonctionnaires du ministère de
l'Information ici en blanc
aux journalistes cet employé fait
visiter la salle d'audience flambant
neuve
voici où ça c'est le juge les membres de
la Cour et les greffiers
c'est ici que la justice catharienne est
censée appliquer les nouvelles lois sur
le salaire minimum ou le temps de
travail
nous recevons énormément de cas
aujourd'hui la séance va commencer à 14h
nous avons 25 affaires à traiter
beaucoup de dossiers concernent des
salariés d'entreprises de construction
on envoie beaucoup beaucoup
nous allons augmenter le nombre de
tribunaux il y en aura bientôt 5 donc 5
juges et on pourra traiter plus
d'affaires
pour le moment la grande majorité des
dossiers sont en attente faute de
personnel
en décembre dernier le ministère a même
reconnu avoir reçu plus de 2000 plaintes
mais n'en avoir traité que 69
les salariés toucheront leur argent que
ce soit l'entreprise la police le pays
ou le fond de solidarité qui paye il
l'obtiendront et l'entreprise sera
condamnée il y a des sanctions oui oui
lesquels il y en a beaucoup et nous
n'avons plus le temps le juge va arriver
donc si vous voulez filmer le tribunal
profitez-en c'est fini
impossible de filmer la salle d'attente
ou d'interroger des plaignants
arrêtez de filmer il faut quitter cette
zone
on doit partir oui vous devez tous
partir
on peut filmer le juge non pas possible
[Musique]
avec ces réformes législatives le Qatar
peut désormais se vanter d'être le pays
le plus progressiste de la péninsule
arabique
mais à l'étage le porte-parole du
Ministère reconnaît à demi-mots que les
textes ne sont pas toujours appliqués
les réformes bien sûr il y avait
quelques chefs d'entreprises qui étaient
opposées à ces lois et je trouve que
c'est normal
les gens ont tendance à être contre le
changement
ou bien tout ce qui est nouveau
mais avec le temps ça avance
maintenant nous sommes dans la phase de
mise en oeuvre et nous devons faire face
à quelques défis nous devons
sensibiliser les chefs d'entreprise
ainsi que les salariés et bien former
les fonctionnaires des établissements
publics ainsi que des ministères
[Musique]
sur les chantiers de Doha les premiers
intéressés ont bien vu quelques progrès
[Musique]
notre entreprise a fait des efforts
avant notre situation était pire
maintenant tout le monde au Qatar touche
au moins 270 euros par mois même tout en
bas de l'échelle on gagne minimum 270
euros
c'est vrai que maintenant il y a des
tribunaux où je peux aller si mon
entreprise commet une atrocité mais ce
n'est pas si simple que ça je ne suis
pas dans mon pays je ne vais pas essayer
de me battre parce que je ne saurais
même pas à qui m'adresser
franchement un ouvrier qui vient d'Inde
du Népal du Bangladesh ou du Sri Lanka
il est là pour travailler et gagner de
l'argent pour faire vivre sa famille et
aider son pays
il ne va pas s'épuiser à se battre ici
au pire il démissionne et il rentre chez
lui
en théorie les nouvelles lois permettent
de condamner des entreprises comme celle
d'Ibrahim
mais dans les faits les ONG
internationales dénoncent une culture de
l'impunité qui perdure
notre situation est bloquée
les tribunaux nous ont dit ne vous
inquiétez pas on s'en occupe on parle à
votre patron jusqu'à ce qu'on perd
d'espoir
c'est ça qu'ils veulent
on a vraiment besoin d'aide pourquoi il
ne nous aide pas
au bout d'un an d'attente
Ibrahim a pu récupérer son passeport et
résilier son contrat de travail mais il
affirme n'avoir jamais touché ses
arrières et de salaire
l'entreprise en cause est bien connue au
Qatar c'est même une récidiviste
dénoncée à plusieurs reprises jusque
dans les médias locaux
[Musique]
la rédaction de doannews incite
d'informations en ligne à suivi
plusieurs affaires
bonjour
comment ça va
où en es-tu du reportage je suis dessus
j'ai déjà bien avancé hier et je termine
aujourd'hui
la société Aljazeera rien à voir avec la
chaîne de télévision du même nom possède
plusieurs filiales dans les secteurs du
BTP de la restauration ou de
l'automobile
dans cet article la journaliste a
enquêté sur un groupe d'agents de
sécurité qui eux aussi n'avaient pas été
payé
on n'est pas la première fois que cette
entreprise en frein la loi
on a déjà couvert le sujet c'est un
exemple parmi d'autres entreprises qui
choisissent d'ignorer la loi et de ne
pas tenir compte des réformes du droit
du travail
après la publication de cet article l'un
des agences sécurité que nous avions
interviewé m'a envoyé un message pour me
dire que son passeport lui avait été
rendu et qu'il avait été payé
mais c'est dommage de voir que deux ans
plus tard cette entreprise commet
toujours les mêmes erreurs
appartient à un riche homme d'affaires
qatarien
la rédaction elle est composée de jeunes
journalistes Palestiniens pakistanais ou
iraniens pour la plupart néo Qatar de
parents venus travailler ici
pour Razan safour rédactrice en chef des
reportages cette double identité les
rend légitimes pour écrire sur leur pays
d'accueil
sur les infos locales pour que les
lecteurs comprennent comment fonctionne
la société catharienne et qui sont les
gens qui vivent au Qatar
on ne veut pas diffuser des clichés sur
les catariens ou la façon de vivre ici
les travailleurs immigrés font partie du
tissu social catharien ce sont eux la
force derrière tous les chantiers et
tous les travaux que vous voyez et dans
la mesure où ils construisent
littéralement le pays c'est important
pour nous d'attirer l'attention sur
leurs conditions de travail leurs droits
et tout ce qui leur
arrivement et les entreprises privées
plusieurs entreprises ont attaqué Doha
news en justice suite aux articles
dénonçant leur pratique illégales
la rédaction assure n'avoir jamais reçu
de menaces de sang sur de la part de
l'État cette liberté de ton est rare
dans les monarchies du Golfe mais Razan
safour c'est qu'au moindre faux pas tout
peut basculer
rouge ce serait d'insulter la famille
royale on ne ferait jamais ça de toute
façon ça n'a aucun intérêt pour personne
personnellement je pense que c'est la
ligne la plus rouge
pour le reste on procède par tâtonnement
on teste les limites et on s'adapte au
fur et à mesure
pour soigner son image d'ouverture en
Occident la famille royale du Qatar
s'efforce de moderniser et libéraliser
les conditions de vie des étrangers
dans une lointaine banlieue de Doha nous
retrouvons les employés Philippines qui
profitent de leur premier jour de congé
depuis 3 ans
[Musique]
elle se rendent dans une des huit
églises de Doha
ici pas de clocher ou de croix à
l'extérieur
[Musique]
depuis 2008 ce pays musulman ultra
conservateur autorise le culte chrétien
à condition que la messe se déroule à
l'abri des regards
[Musique]
ceci est un cadeau du Qatar à l'église
catholique pour que les chrétiens
puissent se recueillir
le pays reste musulman nous ne sommes
qu'une minorité alors en signe de
respect nous nérigeons pas de croix à
l'extérieur
et ce que nous célébrons normalement le
dimanche ici on le fait le vendredi car
c'est le seul moment où les gens sont
libres
malgré les difficultés à 49 ans Rachel
espère rester au Qatar jusqu'à ce que
ses cinq enfants terminent leurs études
à l'université
[Musique]
si je suis venu au Qatar c'est vraiment
pour mes enfants
parce que l'argent gagné ici a beaucoup
de valeur dans mon pays
je prie Dieu pour qu'il soit en bonne
santé pour qu'il finisse leurs études
je leur dis toujours qu'il faut se
battre se battre et se battre encore et
si Dieu le veut on atteindra notre but
le 4 d'accord
[Musique]
dans un quartier populaire de Doha nous
retrouvons phares Anna
la chef d'entreprise fait ses courses
chez de petits commerçants originaire
d'Inde comme elle
au Qatar les Indiens forment la plus
grande communauté d'expatriés
je prends ceci celui-ci et celui-là ça
fait combien ça fait 6 euros
on se connaît depuis 20 ans il avait une
boutique en face et maintenant il s'est
agrandi
comme Farzana ces marchands sont tous
sous la tutelle d'un associé catharien
les petites mains du Qatar savent
qu'elle ne maîtrise pas leur destin la
durée de leur séjour est soumise au bon
vouloir des autorités et toutes vivent
dans l'angoisse d'être renvoyé dans leur
pays
[Musique]
au centre ville de Doha le quartier
dechaireb comptait des centaines de
petites boutiques tenues par des
étrangers
mais à l'approche de la Coupe du Monde
la famille royale a décidé de tout
rénover
les commerçants se sont vus expulsés les
uns après les autres
[Musique]
Hassan est l'un des derniers à ne pas
avoir tiré le rideau
pour ma boutique on n'a pas encore dit
je ne sais pas
de l'autre côté de la rue ils ont reçu
un avis d'expulsion et les marchands
vidé les lieux
je ne sais pas où ils sont allés
dommagements d'autres non
[Musique]
avec les nouveaux immeubles les loyers
vont changer
je pense qu'après la Coupe du monde ils
vont tous nous expulser ça m'inquiète
quand vous habitez ici vous n'êtes pas
un citoyen vous avez seulement un permis
de résidence et vous ne savez pas quand
on va vous demander de partir c'est
comme ça tous les expatriés connaissent
ce sentiment
au bout de 20 ans l'installation de
phares Anna reste précaire
elle cuisine encore sur un réchaud à
pointe car elle a préféré investir ses
économies dans son pays d'origine
j'ai investi dans une maison et un petit
bureau en Inde pour avoir un endroit où
aller si jamais Dieu m'en préserve je
dois partir et
qu'on s'installe ici la première chose
qu'on fait c'est construire un
pied-à-terre chez nous pour pouvoir se
retourner
rêveraient de devenir catharien mais
sauf qu'à exceptionnel il est impossible
d'obtenir la nationalité même pour jacem
néado à il y a 16 ans
tu as fini tes devoirs
j'ai presque fini mais j'ai trouvé ça
dur
tu te sens plutôt indien ou katarien
quel est ton pays
c'est normal tout va bien
il n'aime pas du tout l'Inde comme il
est né et qui il a grandi ici il est
habitué et vous comprenez il est heureux
chez lui
sérieusement même quand on voyage il
veut toujours rentrer à la maison
puisque j'habite ici depuis que je suis
né et puis tout se passe bien ici
tu voudrais rester
oui bien sûr j'aime beaucoup ce pays
dans 10 ans j'aimerais encore habiter
ici au même endroit avoir peut-être un
plus grand bureau plus d'employés
je voudrais faire grossir mon entreprise
et après j'aimerais rester ado à pour ma
retraite
et vous pensez que ça sera facile je
pense que passer 60 ans c'est très
difficile d'avoir un visa donc je ne
sais pas
[Musique]
au Qatar le droit de résidence est lié
au permis de travail
retraiter et chômeurs doivent quitter le
pays
[Musique]
sur la corniche de Doha l'avenir
d'Ibrahim s'assombrit
le jeune homme n'a pas retrouvé dans
l'emploi depuis qu'il a quitté
l'entreprise qui ne le payait pas
il sera donc bientôt expulsable
je ne suis plus salarié d'une entreprise
je n'ai plus de logement
je vis chez des amis
parfois elle me disent on va travailler
sur un chantier viens
ensemble
sinon je prends le métro et je cherche
du travail
je cherche une issue à tout ça
ce pays me faisait rêver j'avais une
vision un but
[Musique]
je pensais qu'en venant ici j'allais
pouvoir aider mes proches
mes parents ma mère
[Musique]
parce qu'elle a vraiment besoin de moi
mais moi je ne vois rien de jolie
quand je regarde ces grands immeubles
je pense à la souffrance de ce qu'ils
ont construit
le temps de la Coupe du monde de
football
Ibrahim espère trouver un petit boulot
mais il craint de devoir rentrer au
Kenya une fois le tournoi terminé encore
plus pauvre qu'à son arrivée
loin du feu des projecteurs le Qatar
pourrait vite abandonner les réformes
adoa des centaines de milliers de
travailleurs risquent de retomber dans
l'oubli
[Musique]
et voilà pour ce reportage sur ces
travailleurs de l'ombre au Qatar on
retrouvera toute l'actualité de cette
coupe du monde sur les antennes de
France 24 dans les semaines qui viennent
merci d'avoir suivi cette émission et on
se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de reporter
[Musique]